the australian lewis thorpe has made one
start for the twins so far this year two
appearances and featured that fastball
slider changing the curve here's isaiah
connor falafa
breaking ball tapped to third donaldson
crosstalk went away high fly center
field buxton back
slamming on the brakes and making the
catch
between the legs right to simmons and a
good first inning for louis thorpe
jung young
his first major league start he has
appeared twice
in relief and he's been great
whoa he got buxton to chase strike three
on a breaking ball that was way up over
the zone one away yeah if you're going
to throw this pitch you're probably
better off hanging it by a lot not just
hanging it a little bit i think they
were actually trying to go below the
zone if you look at jose trevino's glove
and this one finished well above but
that works
another swing of the miss
mullen guys down right now as he strikes
out donaldson two up two down yong's
two-two
and he strikes out the side in order
in his first inning as a starter
stateside as garber bass no score bottom
two
a high fly to left garcia going back
he'll watch it leave
garver
with a long home run his sixth of the
year
well that was a bomb right there he
crushed that ball no doubter again from
garver and
took a couple steps out of the batter's
box and set that bat down and
just watch a fly twins have a lead and a
good sign after a tough loss last night
play with the lead today and get that
good feeling back
also a good sign from garver
polanco strikes out swinging he's the
fourth strikeout now tonight 3-2
whoa strike three called
and kepler down looking that's five
strikeouts in the first two innings for
hyun jungyeon so no leading things off
here oh two
make it eight
and a strikeout of cino
is out number one i'll tell you what to
not only that strikeout but the idea
that i was thinking okay that was a nice
change up maybe throw one out of the
strike zone here see if you can get him
a chase he went right at miguel cino
with this changeup that caught a lot of
the strike zone
and his swing and a miss it's in the
dirt
trevino is going to have to complete the
strikeout by throwing it down to first
base but
yet another seven strikeouts first time
through the order maybe solac
low and then adolesce garcia in the
fourth inning
this one lined out toward right field
drops in base hit
solac takes an aggressive turn at first
but he'll hold there with a lead off
single 3-2 pitch
and that ball hit sharp play to right
field he does
into third base solace they'll stop him
the rangers have runners on the corners
with nobody out
deep down the right field line
foul now
no they're saying home run
and the batter garcia never left home
plate he was waiting for it to slice
foul
and the first base umpire phil cousy
is saying it's a fair ball and a
three-run home run
well
it's gonna get overturned
here clearly foul not by much that
about three feet foul
thorpe wants no part of that saying no
no no no garcia's gonna have to come
back to the batters boxing kind of reset
mentally here
and he went upstairs to get him
well there's one that's huge that's a
that's a big out right there
able to elevate and get him to go above
the zone so one out in here is gallow
it would be cool if they would score
some early and this one the ground ball
it could be two nope don't get just the
one that is out number two but it does
get a run to the plate so we're tied up
tied game as we go to the bottom of the
fourth inning
that's deep to the left field corner
and a fair ball and the third ball of
this series that has bounced out of play
down that left field line
so a double sending cruz the third of
the twins
threatening to retake the lead here
got him swinging and he strikes out
polanco there's that big out one away
it's a really nice job of expanding the
zone maybe a little bit unintentionally
but you'll take it when you can get it
81 miles an hour
on a change of they wanted it down he
threw it up molanco couldn't resist
oh young
well that's got his mount and that is
going to be
going to be
woody
takes the baseball a little handshake
yeah all right that's all good
nice job first big league start for
young and he'll leave with the bases
loaded one out john king coming on
he'd love one here and he gets one here
come back he'll go to the plate for one
on the first not in time but they force
out crews at the plate for the second
out of the inning
2-1 is grounded to short kinder philetha
goes the short way to second and the
inning is done a basis loaded jam but
young and king work out of it impressive
out for lewis thorpe he's going to start
the sixth inning
did he go no and it's a lead-off walk
here in the six to nick solac
3-2 pitch that's bounced through the
right side base head solac heads to
third they'll stop him there low with a
base hit
and the rangers have the first two men
on
and just like in the fourth inning first
and third for adolesce garcia and
buldelli may have seen enough
he makes
the chain one-two pitch whoa that one
bounces off the face mask of garber and
it allows solace to score on the wild
pitch and the rangers take a 2-1 lead in
the sixth inning well you take it any
way that you can get it and it looked
like it was a spiked slider let's take a
look here it was and right off of the
face mask we heard it
on the ground ceno with a great snag and
he'll go to the bag for the out
miguel sano
going horizontal to take an extra base
hit away from joey gallo wow he caught
this ball deep this ball was hit hard
just a play you needed to have to not
let this game get out of hand this ball
gets down in the corner one for sure
maybe two runs are going to score so big
run saving play right here stay shack to
the plate
and that ball
high in the air out to center field
it'll be deep enough to get a run home
buxton is there
tagging is low he'll score
and it's a 3-1 rangers lead bagnes
picks up his first major league rbi that
almost feels like a gift right there
after a couple of sliders and some ugly
swings
stacia goes to the fastball and it was
elevated but in the strike zone
and that was a really nice looking swing
by andy abanyos with two strikes he
drove that ball
all right coleman's in yeah been a
struggle for him alex coleman came over
this year in free agency they wanted him
to be the closer but you can see the
high era
and strikeout
so low strikes out one out first
strikeout for column eight tonight
check swing swing three
[Music]
gets a couple of strikeouts here
good side when he's getting swings and
misses like that
check swings and
awkward looking swings from hitters
white bats
high and deep right center field buxton
chasing it and leaping
and making the catch up against the wall
alkala enjoyed it
and byron buxton that time went to his
left
and saved the double if not three bases
with white speed in right center field
alkala all sorts of fired up ian kennedy
takes over here in the ninth inning now
we're talking about ian earlier he has
been fantastic 17 strikeouts for him so
far this season that is in 13 innings
and did he swing yes he did that is
strike three a strike out of polanco and
there's one away
two two
and there's a swing and a miss another
strikeout for kennedy back-to-back case
freddie's again the o2 and a swing and a
miss strike three he gets simmons and
closes out yet another
his ninth save as the rangers win three
to one